hey come here wait
wait
wait call me by
name his name I can't
remember I can't connect
you all of these moving parts from the
start we were changing I should have
seen the signs all the time will'll be
stages biger scenes and bigger Stars
it's not hard to contain it but to never
lose
it well we got the heart is true don't
want to waste love don't want to hurt
you hurt
you symbiosis a satire onism it seems
satirical maybe it's funny it's just a
circle in a square I didn't know a
circle in a square could be so
[Music]
beautiful get the the Nutty over
Tong a DP there you go I got it I got I
got
[Music]
it were changing I should have seen the
sign all the time we'll be stanging
but you never lose
[Music]
it we got the heartest you don't want to
waste up don't want to hurt you hurt you
LIF our deeper Blues we're going to pull
through we're going to let
hold